now at rebel Wilson yeah is it real that
you did want to be a rapper you and your
sister yeah yeah because there's no
african-americans in Sydney so like
white people like to rap and I had a
little group with my sister Liberty and
this sounds made-up but it's not this
it's true and we went in like shopping
center contests to try to make the money
yeah and just do two stoners yeah like
in the middle of the shops and like
there's a little stage and like little
local kids get up and do an act and like
you might win like 10 bucks and you're
actively aimed in this oh no it was just
like two sisters like I never knew you
were this weird
revel Isha's then um oh that's like when
I sometimes pretend to have a rap
alter-ego and let you know that my name
is rubble be still I did when I it's
like 14 I did a bar mitzvah rap do you
remember any of your raps rebel well we
only used to do covers because that's
what legit rappers do like crisscross
salt and pepper you know or that if I
played a little bit of do you know push
it would you know push it all right
oh do you want to mic microphone looking
everything
it shoes all okay so I just thought the
music
good
they're in an adult situation but they
don't like my language then don't
[__] show us how much is it it's
about 750